what do you think like the top five  vegetables should be then well I would  have to say for one dark leafy greens  and you know I think kale can be I  happen to like kale  it's so divisive so divisive yeah but  I'm not recommending that I'm saying  that like I like it I don't really have  you know any any major issue digesting  it but I think arugula is phenomenal  romaine lettuce yeah mixed greens all  great all great and super nutrient dense  because they're rich in folate and  vitamin C but they provide very few  calories which yeah which increases  their nutrient density right by  definition we know that people who eat a  bowl of dark leafy greens every day have  more youthful brains so brains that  perform up to 11 years younger meat of  all kinds including fish I'm sure yeah  right proteins and you've got fruit  vegetables  what's next are we to Wine yet because  if we're not to like chocolate and wine  I just you know